مرحبًا منى
أحبك إلي ، هل تعلم هل أنت جيد جدًا ،
نعم مثالي ، دعنا نفعل ذلك ، لذا فإن
السفر هو تطبيق سفر
شامل يهتم بكل شيء يتعلق
بتخطيط السفر كما أنه يوفر
إلهامًا للسفر وأشعر أن هذا هو
USB حقًا  لأنك في بعض الأحيان
تخطط لعطلتك القادمة
ولا تعرف إلى أين
تذهب ، هل رأيت تعاونًا تسويقيًا مذهلاً
يحدث شيئًا واحدًا
ساعدنا حقًا وهو الشراكة
والتعاون مع جميع الأشخاص
الموجودين في النظام البيئي ، لذلك لا بأس بذلك حتى
بعض  يمكن أن يكونوا منافسين لذلك
يخبرني الناس مثل كيف
تتعاون مع منافسيك ولكن
عندما تأتي من عقلية الوفرة
وتقول أنك تعرف ما
هو كل شيء هناك ما يكفي
للجميع والسوق كبير جدًا ،
فلنضيف المزيد من الخيارات ونعطي قيمة
للمجتمع ، لذلك عندما تضع التركيز على
مقدار الربح الذي سأحصل عليه ، فمن
الواضح أنه مهم جدًا ، فنحن جميعًا في
مجال الأعمال التجارية ، فهو ليس com الصيني.
الأعمال التجارية هنا ولكن عندما يكون التركيز على
مقدار القيمة التي يمكنني إضافتها إلى
عملائي وحتى عندما أشارك مع المنافسين دعنا نقول ،
يمكنني إضافة المزيد من القيمة
لهم لأن لديهم المزيد من الخيارات
ثم السماح لهم بالاختيار حتى يكون لدينا
أن يكون لديك شراكة مع كل شخص في
النظام البيئي الذي سيقوم المروجون
بالترويج له ، وهو يساعد حقًا في أن يكون الأمر مربحًا للجميع
، ويجب أن يكون دائمًا مربحًا للجانبين ، ولا يمكن أن يكون
ذلك بطريقة واحدة ، لذا من المهم جدًا أن
نعرف سبب قيامنا بما نفعله ،
نعم  وأريد أن أقدم هذه
الراحة ، أعني أنني كنت مندهشًا جدًا ،
فلا أحد يقدمها كما تعلم ، نعم ،
إنه لألم كبير أن تستمر كل هذه
الشراكة كما تعلم أنه ليس من السهل
كيمي
بناء قبيلة هو شيء مهم للغاية
هم ليسوا مجرد أشخاص
عملاؤك هم هم من المعجبين بك ،
الناس الذين يشترون منك يريدون العمل
معك ليس بسبب المنتج فقط
ولكن لأنهم يؤمنون بأن
الناس ليسوا مجرد عملائك
ولكنهم معجبون حقًا وهذا أمر
مذهل "  لقد كان وقتك ثمينًا حقًا ،
فأنا ممتن جدًا لي